este jueves la empresa ucraniana
energoatom anunció la desconexión de la
planta nuclear de sap orilla de la red
eléctrica del país la medida se llevó a
cabo por daños en las líneas eléctricas
provocados por incendios en entrevista
con france 24 el director general del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica rafael cross y anunció que
podría inspeccionar la zona en los
próximos días en estado de shock presión
y si lo que pasa es que esta operación
es extremadamente compleja para empezar
llegar allí esta es una zona de guerra
es
difícil
where we were so were kings ya he estado
allí dos veces estuve en chernóbil donde
también estuve trabajando para
estabilizar la zona y llegar allá es por
supuesto tremendamente complejo y
necesitamos tener toda la seguridad
seguridad en el sentido físico de que no
nos disparen en este sentido el ministro
de defensa de rusia serguéi shoigú
aseguró la asistencia necesaria a los
inspectores de la oiea el anuncio lo dio
a conocer a su homólogo francés
sebastián de core news el ministro
señaló la importancia de las visitas a
la zona de la central por parte del
personal de la oea y la disposición a
brindar la asistencia necesaria a los
inspectores de la organización estos
hechos se concatenan en un movimiento
diplomático internacional que intenta
evitar un desastre en la planta este
jueves el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón recibió a gross y el mandatario
reiteró su respaldo a la visita de los
expertos de la organización desde
ginebra la alta comisionada de la onu
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet se sumó a los llamados de
desmilitarización de la central la
víspera el presidente voló de iniciales
que acusó a moscú ante el consejo de
seguridad de la onu miento de convertir
la planta nuclear en una zona de combate